There's another very worthwhile
optimization we can do to our
JavaScript, and it's quite similar
to how we use Sass instead of CSS.
Turns out there is a way of running
the very latest spec of JavaScript,
ECMASript 6, even though there's
no native browser support for
many of the features.
All we need is a transpiler, which
takes one programming language, and
converts it into another.
Sometimes transpilers stay very
close to ECMAScript syntax,
adding in a few features here and there.
In other cases, they are full
implementations of languages you
don't typically find in purely
front end web development.
We'll stick to the former category.
Our transpiler of choice is Babel JS.
It's very popular, feature rich and
well supported by the community.
Now of course this step
is purely optional.
If you're happy with today's JavaScript
and don't need all the fanciness, great.
But if you're curious to try out
arrow functions, generators and
classes, now is the perfect time.
And sure enough, getting this into our
code is as simple as everything else.
Just grab the gulp-babel plugin and
require it in your gulp file.
And in both script task,
pipe it after the gulp.src, but
before the concatenation.
You won't see any difference right away,
as you're not actually using any
ES6 magic in your current code.
So head over to Babel's ES6
learning page and
get familiar with some of the concepts.